what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
you know if I can get my hands on a copy
of the cover that's big enough or if I
didn't like blow it up in Photoshop
without losing too much quality I think
I'm gonna make posters out of the covers
for the dark nights metal tie-ins
because these are amazing oh my god dude
murder machine man dude it is god it's
beast this is an amazing story okay so
like all the other Dark Knights metal
tie-ins that we've done this comes out
of issue number two really well you
should have a warning mission number two
but the stories themselves the origins
themselves are still standalone in the
sense that they're basically just the
stories of how these evil versions of
Batman came to be but the whole idea
here is that this sinners on this
amazing version of Batman
so this initially picked up with Victor
stone right with cyborg and the only
thing that's really ties into in terms
of the Dark Knight's metal is just the
idea that Victor stones father is really
just kind of analyzing this idea of this
in metal again this metal that
everybody's aware of or everybody's
basically learning about the kind of
resonates with another plane of
existence now one thing to keep in mind
and we'll talk about this more once we
get into Dark Knights metal when it
comes to the DC Multiverse the different
universes are accessible due to
vibration airy patterns I mean think of
the vibrations as a wall if you can
vibrate at the right frequency that wall
basically disappears and you can walk
right into another universe the cool
thing about this is that that's the
nature of enth metal it's this metal
that vibrates at frequencies of another
you know multiversal plane and it is the
manner by which people you know that
Dark Knights can access the main DC
Multiverse so it's kind of the cool
thing that goes on but in the middle of
Vic basically talking with his dad he
suddenly met by the arrival of murder
machine and that's kind of the cool
thing about this is unlike the other
origin stories so far for the most part
they follow a linear progression you
have like one of these evil versions of
Batman that shows up and then fights
someone and then you jump into the
origin story with this one and actually
kind of bounces back and forth in
between the two but the way that this
works is that this version of Batman
hails from earth negative 44 in the dark
multiverse and it's this idea that in
this reality that the various villains
of Batman's rogues gallery know Killer
Croc and Harley Quinn and you know
two-face were basically all led by Bane
in a campaign to find out where Batman
was they effectively broke into the
Batcave and then just tortured Alfred
and then eventually killed him keep
Alfred's not just a butler for the Wayne
family Alfred is Bruce Wayne surrogate
father that's the role he's always
played when it came to the various
stories of Batman whether it's an
alternate reality story whether it's the
main DC Universe it's always been
Batman's parents were shot in a dark
alley and a mugging gone wrong and
Alfred basically raised him as a son and
so to have Alfred stripped away from
Batman he effectively crosses this line
he can't come back from psychologically
because for Batman for Bruce Wayne
he lost his biological father which
motivated him to become Batman then he
loses Alfred his surrogate father what
comes next
will you do the only thing you can do
you try to find a way to cope and with
the idea of Bruce Wayne what he did is
he basically went to a cyborg and said I
backed up Alfred's mind once upon a time
and I would like to turn him into an AI
because I can't do it on my own now this
is just Bruce Wayne grieving right I
mean that's that's the beauty of this
whole thing
it is him basically reliving his own
father's death but there's an out that's
the beauty of it he's like there's a way
for me to save Alfred and it's not Bruce
Wayne doing it because he's just like oh
I just I need I'm so used to Alfred I
have to have him around it's basically
his dad it's a surrogate father Alfred
is the voice of reason
Alfred is the one Bruce Wayne goes to
when he throws his hands in the air says
I don't know what to do next
am I really even making any progress
saving Gotham City Alfred is the
reassurance Alfred is the one that says
all you can do is the best you can and
as long as you think that you're doing
things the right way as long as you are
living up to what your father would
believe is an admirable role then follow
the path that you're currently on
Alfred is the bedrock by which the
entire moral compass of Bruce Wayne is
built to have that taken away and then
to have a momentary second where he can
get that back he'll do anything to make
that happen and that's what we end up
finding out in this massive fight
between you know Victor stone and murder
machine between cyborg and murder
machine the entire time it's basically
murder machine sank in my universe
you're the one that made it possible
you're the one that helped me to become
Who I am but what we end up learning is
that when the AI are when the Alfred AI
was completed the AI immediately went to
Skynet it just went all Skynet it just
is lost his mind you know Alfred becomes
Skynet what a title um but the whole
idea is that the Alfred AI basically
went awry it went nuts
and it started going through creating
physical copies of itself or at least
he's kind of nano
copies of itself and started hunting
down every single member of Batman's
rogues gallery every single enemy that
he has it started eliminating all of
them this is a beautiful scenario to
behold I mean not the death of Bane I
mean it's not you know a beautiful thing
that he was killed by the AI but the
logic behind it is what's so beautiful
about it Batman is by definition about
as logical and reasonable as a being can
get in the DC Universe Batman I wouldn't
say is devoid of emotion but the
emotions he has he keeps at bay and so I
would make a legitimate argument the
Batman is actually more machine than man
just because of the fact that he seems
so emotionless he's so cold and
calculating but in this instance it's
his emotions come to bear his desire to
get his surrogate father back when
cyborgs of Earth negative 44 shows up
and says this AI is going crazy and it's
killing people we have to shut it down
Batman's responses No we can make it
better we can make it work we can make
it do what it's supposed to and that's
the beauty of all this it's because it's
him essentially sitting down and saying
I don't want to let him go the other
half of this is that the AI itself is
basically programming the AI is not
inherently evil it is an artificial
intelligence that's built on ones and
zeros in this particular instance the AI
was programmed to carry out the desires
of Alfred Alfred's most based desire was
to keep Bruce Wayne safe and so the
programming is doing the most logical
thing
keep Bruce Wayne safe well the most
dangerous thing to Bruce Wayne are as
enemies Bane Brooke is back in nightfall
all the enemies of Batman has seek to
eliminate him so the most logical thing
to do to protect Bruce Wayne is to get
rid of his enemies it makes perfect
sense if you're a computer and that's
the basis behind this
Alfred was effectively brought back by
Bruce Wayne Alfred was resurrected in
the form of an artificial intelligence
but the one thing that the Alfred AI
doesn't have that differentiates a
machine from a human is a soul the
ability to understand that things are
not ones and zeros that they're nuanced
that there is no such thing is black and
white that there's black and white and
then a zillion shades of gray and so
because of that because of the fact that
this AI doesn't grasp that at the end of
the day it does what's logical and it
does what's reasonable but for Bruce
Wayne himself he's emotional under
normal circumstances any reasonable
person who was as logical as this
computer system would say well that
doesn't make any sense I mean the
Computers you know executing people and
Batman doesn't abide by that Batman
doesn't tolerate that we have to shut it
down
Bruce Wayne's response of saying we know
we can fix it we can make it better
faster than it was before
it's his emotions but there's no
guarantee that this will work but that's
the that's the beauty of it is because
while the Dark multiverse is the
opposite of what we would expect from
the main DC Universe its opposite in
both its physical structure and its
opposite in terms of how the characters
function and so in this instance we end
up finding out that the goal of cyborg
was to shut down the AI before it can
spread any further Bruce Wayne wanted to
fix it letting it into the Batcave the
AI immediately latched itself onto Bruce
Wayne and started modifying his genetic
structure effectively turning him into a
machine turning him into a robot and
that's kind of the irony of all this is
because it's not until Batman and the
earth negative 44 universe becomes this
villain that exists according to codes
and machines that he becomes almost
identical to his version in the main DC
Universe it hits home to the idea that
Batman's almost inhuman in terms of how
cold and calculating that he is but in
response to the earth negative 44 Batman
merging with the Alfred AI and basically
going on this rampage it results in
cyborg gathering the Justice League and
then murder machine killing them all
every last one the Green Lantern the
flash
Wonder Woman Superman the whole nine
yards every last one of them falls with
this murder machine making all these
duplicate copies of himself attacking
cities until cyborgs the only one left
and were cyborgs in the earth negative
forty four universally responds by
saying I know there's still some human
part of you that's in there I know
there's still some part of you that
feels emotion that's still reasonable
you have to listen we can bring you back
murder machine Batman's responses but
why though like I'm happy where I am
I'll never have to worry about losing
Alfred again he and I are one we're
combined into the same mind we function
according to the same whims and wants
I've gotten what I wanted out of this
now that's the cool thing about that is
because this juxtaposes directly to the
main DC Universe Batman one of the
biggest issues that like the various
members of the bat family bring out time
and time again that the writers always
focus on is it's his way or the highway
it's what he wants to do and then
nothing else matters as long as he gets
what it is that he wants superheroes
have that issue with Batman we saw that
in terms of all the secrecy we saw that
in terms of all the cloak-and-dagger
stuff that he pulls in the Tower of
Babel
learn that Batman had this database on
how to defeat the members of the Justice
League and never told them about it and
so again this whole idea of Batman being
dark being twisted being sinister in
this capacity is almost like an outward
manifestation of who he really is in the
main DC Universe and so that's why
that's so cool so ultimately he kills
the earth negative 44 version of cyborg
which results in of course the man who
lost popping up and simply saying we can
make everything better your earth is
going as falling apart your universe is
coming to an end but I know a place I
know of a universe where we can
basically take over everything we can
conquer it and move in an outward
direction of course all of this
basically being done at the request of
Barbados so it's really murder machine
Batman being recruited like all the
others by the man who lost after request
to Barbados it's super cool in terms of
how all this comes together and how it
functions but notice this where you know
this version of cyborg from the main DC
Universe has just easily taken out by
all these different versions of Batman
but it's cool to see this happen because
at the end of the day cyborg isn't
whisked away by dr. fate he's not
suddenly yanked out and say oh man we
need you he's basically left there now
of course he's taken prisoner by the
Dark Knights of Barbados and probably
gonna be used for some future some
future project but again this is
probably one of the best origin stories
that I've seen come out of dark nights
metal it is nothing short of spectacular
my god is one of the best stories I have
a rad there's there's no two ways about
it there's no arguing with that point
this is this is amazing it is it's
hands-down one of the absolute best
stories I've ever read I mean it's you
guys need to go out and buy this because
it is it is super good but with that
being said guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained and make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the robbed Court if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
and